While most companies understand the benefits of
automation and have even adopted some automation
capabilities into their operations, it can
be challenging to achieve the full value of
an automation solution. Especially when faced
with potential challenges like prioritizing, or
scaling automation projects across the enterprise.
Businesses need an automation solution that will
identify what processes and projects will be
best served by automation for the greatest ROI.
With flexible deployment options that allow
them to get started quickly and easily.
And finally, they need an intelligent automation
strategy that can be incorporated into existing
systems and scaled easily. Enter IBM Cloud Pak
for Business Automation. With a modular set
of integrated software, Cloud Pak for Business
Automation is built for any cloud and offers a
broad set of AI-powered automation capabilities,
including process mining, RPA, content, capture,
decisions, and workflow. You can integrate it into
your existing environments wherever you are today
and scale easily while bringing security
and transparency to your operations.
As an AI-powered automation solution, you can
use IBM Cloud Pak for Business Automation to
augment your workforce with AI and digital
employees freeing your human employees to
focus on higher value work. Automate your core
operations to improve efficiency and productivity.
Create business applications easily with no
and low code tools to give business leaders
the agility to deliver better customer
experiences. You can apply actionable
insights using deep learning to obtain
AI-powered recommendations for shared data.
And apply intelligence to processes and tasks for
more agile operations and continuous improvement.
And finally measure impact with built-in
analytics to track your business performance.
IBM Cloud Pak for Business Automation is
already helping to transform operations
and speed innovation for a variety of businesses.
For example, by achieving straight through
processing for 97 of new margin and option
requests, TD Ameritrade maintained top-notch
customer service during skyrocketing demand.
By enabling financing applicants to submit
documentation for mobile devices, Turkcell
reduced approvals from days to minutes. With IBM
Cloud Pak for Business Automation you can make
every experience and process more intelligent.
If you have any questions please drop us a line
below. And if you want to see more videos like
this in the future, please like and subscribe.